your boy tom holland said he would love  a cameo i mean what does he have to do  to show up listen we talked about it you  know because he supported me through the  whole season and we joke about like just  fitting him into the background  it was an easter egg see if someone  couldn't spot him did you see this tweet  go viral it's literally maddie like in  the hallway in an outfit with her tiny  purse girl doesn't even have a pen my  sister sent me that yesterday and my  cousin commented she does all the work  in her head and i said true she just she  goes to sleigh we don't need the pencil  we don't need the book  oh whoa when does this interview come  out we're getting way too far ahead